Woah. Wow
Hey Guys Welcome Back to Another Random Experiment Today I'm here With my buddy tony Stark Because
We're Gonna be Testing to see Whether you can Let off Gunpowder
With A stun gun [so] here's the deal This Company Called Loot
Crate Just Ship this Box to my House and I have no [idea] what's inside I guess that's why
They Call it a mystery Box [but] you and I are Gonna Rip This Thing open and See what kind of fun we Can have
Today With [Whatever's] in it hey I got an iron man [Check] that out so here's [Where]
We're Gonna answer the Question will Electricity ignite Gunpowder
Let's go give it a try
[Now] the Gunpowder I'm going to be using Is a muzzleloading Propellant and it's not True black Powder but it is a triple Fg
Equivalent and I thought it'd be Fun to build a fairly nice Pile of this Stuff Although this is going to be very Dangerous and
I could not recommend Anybody try this at
Home
This Little Toy has a Button when you press it the Arc Reactor lights up which Is pretty cool and the neat Thing [about] This
Toy is its [100%] metal, [oh]?
No I just ran out of Juice, [oh]
You got, to be Kidding me my taser Just died and I don't think I have enough Time to charge it dang it now
We don't have very much Time to Work [With] here Because we've got A severe Thunderstorm?
Rolling in Right now so we've got A very Limited Window of
Opportunity Work With now This is A real Bummer Guys Because you Probably know That Water and Gunpowder don't mix if This stuff Gets Wet
It's not gonna Work it's Really, Really, Really Bad Timing for something like This to happen rain Is not good
Well Needless to say I didn't Make it Just Camped out While this rain Settles Down how. Would you look at. That now [Kalin]
[Alright] it Looks like, We got a little Break in the Clouds so let's run out and Try That again
How's our Little Mascot doing over here, did he Survive
That Guy
Is made of a hundred percent diecast Metal this Thing is Completely Soaked
Alright The rain Subsided Just A bit and I got my stun gun [charged] so let's give This Another Shot
Yeah!
It Worked it Worked Look, Look at that that was a really cool, Reaction that was awesome
[Wouldn't] The Fire Look at the way that Just went Up in Flames
and he's a little bit warm to the touch and you can See a little bit of Residue on the Outside but other Than that
He's in Perfect [Shape]
Let's go Bigger I'm Gonna go Ahead and use pretty much the whole rest of the Bottle here This Should, be a pretty good Reaction
Now we've got iron man Buried up [to] his Knees and Gunpowder?
And a little Trail of powder Back here so I have Just a second or [two] to get out of the
Way all right let's do it, [oh]?
oh
Wow a little Buzz from that
Wow
Look at that that is Amazing Look at that Cloud of smoke, [oh] wow [Look] he's Still Steaming
And oh Look at that the Arc Reactor Still Works
That is so cool
Now I admit this did Catch me a little bit Off-Guard when it went Up in Flames you can See as it starts to spark
and i jump off the Flame Grows About
As fast as I could get away [from] it pretty much Engulfs the entire
Table in Flame and [then] the smoke [Just] Goes Up in A Huge Mushroom Cloud that Looks so cool
Yeah and our [Captain] [America] got a little over Spray but other than that it's Umberto There's a little bit of a Scorch Mark There
other Than That no real damage, [well] Guys That
Was a ton of fun big Thanks to loot Crate for Providing These Toys to [play] with Loot
Crate is a Monthly [Subscription] Box Service for Epic geek and Gamer items and for Pop Culture
Gear for Less Than $20 a Month you get six to eight items that include Licensed gear Apparel
Collectibles Unique One-Of-A-Kind Items and More, We create Guarantees [$40.00] [of] Value in Every Crate most of the Time it's A lot more They
Also Shipped over 28 Different Countries and They're More Than Just a subscription Service
It's more like an entire Community of Fans That Share Their Experience and Interact With each other Around the
Unboxing of each Months Crate the Cutoff for the next Loop Crate is going to be on the 19th of this Month
[so] if You want one You better hurry and Sign up what you Still Can [and] that Kids going to be Exploring some of the
Things That Can go wrong With Dystopia, you, Can Expect to see gear Featuring Robocop Terminator 2 Judgment day and [the] [Matrix] as
Well as Bioshock Infinite and Fallout 4 so guys if you want to get a service that sends cool
Merchandise Like This to your House Every Month in A mystery Box go sign up at loot, crate Comm
Slash The King of Random and Enter the promo Code the king of Random for 10% Off and Remember the Cutoff for one of These
Boxes Is on the 19 so if you want to get One for Yourself You better hurry over and Sign up while you still can
Anyway Thanks for Joining Me in This Experiment Guys and I'll be Looking for you the next one Talk to you then
Now I've got a Scorched iron man and a since Captain America hat that I want to give to some of you [let] me Know
In the Comments What [Kind] of A contest, We Can run Where i can give These things away and Look he Still Works
Thanks for watching